ce n'est pas cocu on est pas heureux il
faut être cocu dans la vie
être chi on vit depuis quelques semaines
dans une grande effervescence on prépare
comme tous les ans là-bas la fête du
village avec son grand défilé et surtout
l'élection du roi et de la reine mais à
être chi la fête du village c'est la
fête des cocus et bien qu'il s'agisse là
d'une vieille tradition il y a des gens
là-bas qui ne sont pas contents du tout
au point que une véritable querelle
s'est engagée sur le sujet il y a ceux
qui sont pour et il y a ceux qui sont
contre la lorgnette elle a mené son
enquête je trouve que retrouver par
exemple défiler dans la rue
avec des clochettes des cornes enfin
pour moi ça ça ne me convient absolument
pas par exemple je connais une
personnalité actuelle dans la commune
qui a défilé les premiers jours avec des
cornes en tête et ben je trouve que
c'est c'est quand même d'un goût assez
douté très bien moi je la trouve très
bien la fête des cocus
on est pas heureux une fois il calcule
dans la vie je n'ai jamais aimé ce genre
de fête populaire alors et puis alors le
mot cocu bon bah
la fête des cocus dans le temps alors on
rigolait il y avait un homme il y a une
grotte de grande corne faisait tout le
pays avec les cornes des cocus
moi je trouve ça très bien il faut pas
qu'il a supprime à votre avis madame
avez-vous fait partir un moment ou un
autre de votre vie de cette catégorie de
gens qui n'en sais rien je vais pas le
savoir voilà moi j'ai peut-être été
coque mon mari me lame tel tu es aussi
mais je l'ai jamais vu bon je m'en fous
allez au revoir
est-ce que vous êtes dans le défilé
je pense que j'ai jamais été cocu j'aime
bien la fête des cocus il y a beaucoup
de beaucoup de gens d'ici qui sont bien
sûr qui c'est qui l'est pas vous le
savez vous si vous êtes costaud pourquoi
tu voilà faut le savoir ça avant à votre
avis il faut le savoir
pas du tout
la société vous comprenez l'histoire et
des invités d'honneur on peut en trouver
à condition qu'on les radiales si vous
voulez y aller vous avez plein de monde
après fait du manque voulu payer à boire
et à manger il vient toujours vous
auriez penser à quelqu'un vous ah bah je
sais pas un espèce de ministre
quelconque ça
je sais pas le ministère indien
peut-être comment s'appelle celui-ci du
trot de grâce Trudeau
allons-y poutre d'eau moi je veux bien
et pour l'inviter dis-moi qui paye à
boire qui donne à manger il va venir ce
gars-là
[Rires]
[Musique]